also ich sage wir haben 14 3 egger die
richtige antwort hier lautet 24
hallo mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren wir machen heute den wenn du alle
zehn rätsel löst bist du ein genie test
dafür habe ich da hinten auch schon mal
vorbereitet und zwar wer das liest es
doof scheiße wolltest du nicht schon
immer wissen ob denn dir nicht
vielleicht ein verborgenes chemie steckt
ja ich bin seit juni bei mir drin auch
wenn wir heute keinen professionellen iq
test mit ihr durchführen können haben
wir in diesem video 10 rätsel die deinen
verstand ordentlich auf die probe
stellen wäre okay also sind keine
matheaufgaben oder irgendwie sowas
sondern ist ein rätsel
die wir heute lösen müssen fangen wir
mit einer kleinen knobelaufgabe an ok
das ist jason jamerson sitzt im
gefängnis und möchte fliehen
er hat allerdings nur eine schaufel und
nur zwei tage zeit bevor man findet okay
wie entkommt jason aus dem gefängnis
auch und ein kleiner tipp noch es ist
keine option einen tunnel zu graben
ok ich hätte die direkt gesagt gerade
einfach einen tunnel also das hier ist
der liebe jason und er hat eine schaufel
und dort oben ist ein fenster
ja es gibt zwei möglichkeiten erstens er
schaufel den ganzen dreck hier zu einem
berg hoch und kletterte über den berg
raus oder er stellt die schaufel dahin
und klettert über die schaufel raus ja
mehr möglichkeiten sich als nicht
genutzt seine schaufel um unter dem
kleinen fenster einen großen haufen erde
zu platzieren ja so klar dann kletterte
er auf den erdhaufen und durch das
fenster in seine freiheit das erste
rätsel haben wir geschafft aufgabe
nummer 2 welche dieser zahlen passt
nicht zu den anderen
[Musik]
sogar auf zeit aber wir scheißen wieder
auf die zeitweilig muss das ganze auch
aufnehmen also welche zahl passt nicht
in die reihe 90 42 15 27 38 und 63 ich
glaube dass ich tatsächlich keine ahnung
hätte wenn ich das innerhalb von zehn
sekunden
ich habe gar keine ahnung harris check
da gar nichts die richtige lösung ist
die 38 alle anderen zahlen sind durch
drei teilbar mit einer natürlichen zahl
als ergebnis
ich habe die ganze zeit gedacht durch
neuen teilbar aber sehr logisch hier
kommt 30 raus hier kommt 14
da hat schon also ein genie bin ich
schon mal nicht das stimmt kommen wir
zur dritten aufgabe
welches dieser wörter passt nicht zu den
anderen
ist es jetzt nur noch so was passt nicht
dazu da was also wir haben nebel gras
lage sein glaube und tor
wieder absolut keinen plan nebel ist
halt natur gras ist auch natur aber lage
sein glaube und thorsten nichts natur
oder hat das wieder irgendwas mit
grammatik oder so zu tun richtig ist
hier das wort glaube herr alle anderen
wörter ergeben rückwärts gelesen ein
anderes wort bei nebel leben bei gras
sagt weil
er hat mich ja komplett von vorne nach
hinten
ich bin ich echt so blöd ja und jetzt
zur aufgabe nummer vier
welcher dieser buchstaben passt nicht zu
den anderen
[Musik]
nicht wahr ich dachte erst vokale aber
wir haben ja zwei vokal und zwar und
dann haben wir noch xf h und dms um die
striche geht ist es hier ein
durchgezogener steht hier hier hier
nicht keine ahnung
die richtige antwort ist hier der
buchstabe f alle anderen buchstaben sind
nämlich achsen symmetrisch
komplett an meinem großen die sind alle
achsen symmetrische wort zum gabi boni
wie kommt man auf so was da kann keiner
sagen dass er darauf gekommen ist kommen
wir zur fünften aufgabe wie ist es
möglich mit diesen beiden behältnissen
genau vier liter abzumessen
gar nicht gekauft ihren vier liter eimer
also werden wir in wasserhahn und einen
fünf liter gefäß und 1 3 liter gefäß wir
brauchen allerdings exakt 4 liter
scheiße
[Musik]
ich weiß es nicht
ich weiß es wirklich nicht
wirklich einfach so vorgehen dass sich
bei dem fünf liter eimer meine hand
irgendwie hierhin packen würde das ist
der ca dann 80 davon 114 liter ja ich
bin echt gespannt auf die lösungen um
genau 4 liter abzumessen muss man
zunächst fünf liter in das große
behältnis finden dann fühlt man den drei
liter behälter mit der 5 liter-flasche
auch okay in der kleinen flasche sind
also drei und in der großen 23 nun gibt
man die drei liter aus der kleinen
flasche außen und füllt die zwei liter
aus der großen in die kleine nora dann
fällt man fünf litern die große flasche
und füllt ein liter davon wieder in die
kleine flasche kommen wir zur sechsten
aufgabe welches dieser drei
einschusslöcher ist zuerst entstand bzw
welche kugel wurde zu ehren abgefeuert
wie
wenn man das denn wissen ich habe
absolut keine ahnung ich glaube das ist
der satz den ich in diesem video bisher
meisten gesagt habe ich würde einfach
mal sagen nummer zwei weil das
einschussloch am größten ist und weil es
am nächsten an dem typen daran dass aber
eine richtige begründung dafür habe ich
nämlich die richtige antwort ist kugel
nummer zwei das lässt sich daran
erkennen dass die risse die die anderen
kugeln in die wand gemacht haben bei den
rissen die die zweite kugel verursacht
hat aufhören
genau das war auch das was ich mir dann
gedacht hab aufgabe nummer 7 welches
wort suchen wir das kritisieren ist eine
betende frau irgend ein altes gebäude
und
so
medaillen orden ich kompletter voll spaß
das hier sind halt die orden und das
hier ist halt ein orden
also das gleiche wort aber war sie eine
andere bedeutung also rdn
wenn es das jetzt nicht jetzt habe ich
mich wieder komplett zum affen gemacht
richtig ist hier das wort orden ja und
welches wort suchen wie hier bei der
aufgabe nummer acht
wir müssen wieder ein wort suchen dem
einmal eine wiese mit dem
sonnenuntergang wir haben eine straße
wir haben ein schnell fahrendes auto und
wir haben wollten
wir sind zu hause
okay das ist besser als es mit dem orden
auf jeden fall ass en hier sind halt
zwei bilder wo es um rasen geht ich habe
erst an wie sie die ganze zeit gedacht
weil hier in die runde und es ist aber
halt kein und hier rasen halt autos
beziehungsweise hier ist einfach eine
straße verschwommen jetzt das richtige
wort das wort rasen einerseits im sinne
der wiese
andererseits im sinne von
geschwindigkeitsüberschreitungen im
straßenverkehr nice ok wird zur neunten
auf gabor letzte wer von diesen beiden
herren wird in dieser situation auf
jeden fall sterben
mal ganz kurz
ich habe wirklich wieder keine ahnung
eigentlich würde ich sagen dass beide
auf jeden fall sterben werden
weil wenn er hier runter fällt dann wird
er hat noch im fallen ihn abschießen
aber wenn er hier nicht abgeschossen
wird dann wird er mit runtergezogen weil
er ja durch die katapult situation dann
mit oft auch runter wer von diesen
beiden herren wird in dieser situation
auf jeden fall sterben
da muss man halt sagen wer wird auf
jeden fall sterben ist die fragestellung
also nummer eins wird safe sterben würde
ich sagen person 1 ja wenn sie nämlich
person zwei erschießt bedeutet das dass
person zwei zusammen sagt nun person 1
also in den abgrund für jahr genau und
wenn person zwei von sich aus von brett
springt dann war es das sowieso für
person ein okay
außer person 1 kann halt fliegen oder so
und jetzt die letzte aufgabe die wir
zeigen wird ob du ein genie bist oder
nicht wie viele dreiecke siehst du hier
ich hasse das 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
wir haben sogar noch mehr hier ist halt
auch noch und zwölfter
hier ist noch ein dreizehntes und hier
ist noch ein 14 pendants
war es dann auch also ich sage wir haben
14 3 egger die richtige antwort hier
lautet 24 24 dreiecke will ich komplett
blind verdammt und habe ich mich im
fleisch auf erzählt konntest du mit
diesem video deine generalität beweisen
oder nicht und wenn nicht an welchen
aufgaben bist du gescheitert fast alle
gerne mal in die kommentare
ja ich glaube ich fünf richtig
beantwortet und fünf komplette reihen
geschliffen allerdings will ich das
wieder an der ist jetzt auch beenden
meine lieben zuschauer mit dieses video
einfach vorgeschlagen weil es
siebeneinhalb millionen aufrufe hat und
ich habe mir gedacht ich bin ein genie
also mache ich mal den test auf einem
kanal wenn es euch gefallen hat das
gerne einen daumen hoch bei diesem video
hier da und schreibt mir gerne auch
unten in die kommentare was ihr davon
alles wusste oder ob ihr genauso dumm
seit wie ich
[Musik]